we have been looking at physiological
monitoring to try to infer how hard
people are working on a given task what
we've been trying to do is find the
least intrusive means for collecting
physiological data we were looking at
the aviation domain but it can obviously
be extended to a lot further a lot of
other areas so initially we had a lab
study which looked at a very simple
computer task where people wore tracking
balls and shooting them and we could
quite easily varied demand by increasing
and decreasing the number of balls you
know given pattern and then we could see
if the physiological measures reflected
that that pattern and correlated well
with it so that was a lab study to see
how feasible this is and then we went on
to doing a helicopter simulator studying
one of the questions that we had was
would highly trained individuals and
helicopter pilots react in much the same
way as unusual person does you know to
increased level of demand we did a
computer found something that sounds
similar where Horia was using a brain
scanner and turning lights red when
people were practicing things like air
traffic control is this a similar kind
of idea yes the idea behind it is
basically the same the f nurse sensors
what I was using is maybe more accurate
in certain scenarios and reflects more
of the brain activity we're aiming to
use thermal imaging as a way to make it
less intrusive so people don't have to
wear any sort of equipment so this small
flirt thermal camera
the resolution is quite small it's 640
by 480 so it's not an amazing resolution
there are high resolution cameras
nowadays but still not
up to the level of phone camera what it
does it's picking up thermal radiation
this should be within the range of 7.5
to I think 13 micrometers and it's
converting it to temperature so
obviously that's one step of the way the
other the next step was extracting
temperature from various areas of the
face I'm hiding behind a camera here
this is the scale here on the right blue
is cold black is even colder and then as
you go towards red yellow and white that
symbolizes higher temperature yeah when
we extracted the data we used these sort
of images to find facial features those
facial features allowed us to get data
from various areas we covered quite a
large area of the face whereas previous
study looked at smaller areas like the
nose forehead and indeed actually it
most of the changes occur there and on
the nose and around the nose area people
have reported it before we try to do
more structural study where we could
control the demand in a more accurate
way so what we've seen that usually in
most people but not in all of them nose
temperatures tend to drop when they are
engaged in a high demand task and
actually they do tend to go back up as
the testament diminishes the nose tip is
the most evident point but also the side
areas of the nose show a similar
response just not as large here in gray
you can see the perceived demand so
there are three levels of the task
towards the mean of each of the levels
the demand Peaks yeah things get more
difficult and at the same time you can
see here in green for example which is
temperature in point
P which was the tip of the nose you can
see how that drops and then as the task
becomes easier again it starts going
back up this year in blue is point V
which was right below the nose so here
you can see also drop maybe it's not as
high but still you can see sort of the
same pattern we got a similar pattern in
most people and in a lot of helicopter
pilots some other people do have
naturally colder noses they're just
called by default so then there won't be
any meaningful drop in temperature
that's yeah one of the one of the other
effects but yeah we're still exploring
to see if for those cases there are
other signs indicating to the increasing
demand is this something that you can do
in real time or how does it work we can
actually do it in almost real-time with
the algorithm I used which I have to
admit is not highly optimized but you
could do it maybe one frame per second
the camera itself does not output a very
high frame rate it's around 7.5 frames
per second it's actually limited you
cannot buy it at higher frame rates and
yeah then the videos are quite large
because it's the data is not compressed
as you would get normal visual video so
it could end up being within the range
of 30 GB for for one of the videos and
then yeah there's it's quite a lot of
data to process initially the video is
outputted in digital level that the
camera records which is then converted
to actual temperatures by using a
calibration curve and then we used that
temperature base B matrix to convert it
to a visual RGB using a color map which
obviously can
change the format coming after the
camera is is digital so it's the
temperatures and then you convert that
to video do you ever go back from the
video the visual video back to the
original to get the temperatures yes yes
I do that at the ends once you get an
area of interest and you need to extract
data from it then you go to the original
matrix of temperatures and you get the
temperature area from that in between
those specific coordinates we're used to
seeing a pixel as being three or four
numbers while GBL for whatever so
instead of having that you've got a
temperature yeah you just have a
temperature well I used to convert it in
Celsius but you can convert it in any
unit based on that color map we did
tracking of features we had various
approaches treat the first approach from
the paper that was published relied on
cascade classifiers to detect the eye
area so it was trained to to pick up eye
patterns and to find the eyes and then
we would rely on another property of the
thermal image the pupils are colder than
the surrounding so if you look at this
rectangle which is zoomed in here this
is in actual thermal data so whereas
here you see the RGB picture the height
of this represents temperature so you
could see here how temperature drops
across the pupil so this is basically
the center of the pupil the low
temperature there is most likely because
there is no blood vessels passing
through the pupil then he could quite
accurately find the center of the pupil
and then going from there we found the
rest of the landmarks for the helicopter
study using this smaller camera we used
a different approach which actually
didn't belong to us we retrained an
algorithm that was previously published
and it's more robust to post your
changes and it works better and faster
we trained the algorithm to pick up
these specific points on the on the face
it does fail points in extreme angles
but then we filtered out those intervals
as you can see as we go to the video the
nose gets colder this pilot was going
through a very very difficult scenario
where he was performing an auto rotation
which means that he had no more engine
power and he was just going down and
trying to cushion the landing just by
using the propellers that were not
spinning at the moment here as you can
see be crushed and you can see the nose
being really really cold okay he laughed
yeah well luckily it was a simulator you
can laugh after can you remind me what
perfect stillness the lights are about
five seconds behind what max is going
through this March it takes from the
heart to pump up the blood 32-bit images
that is four channels per pixel
it's very common even when we're not use